accès si c'est le nom de cet autocar un
peu particulier il peut accueillir
jusqu'à dix fauteuils roulants le groupe
lacroix et sa vague possède trois
véhicules de ce type les mairies nous
sollicitent régulièrement pour des
transport des personnes à mobilité
réduite et donc nous avons imaginé ce
véhicule qui peut transporter 10
fauteuils en même temps et il est
modulable donc de 42 places assises
jusqu'à dix places assises et en
fonction fait varier le nombre de
fauteuils de un à dix fauteuils qui est
bien sûr semblait dans le véhicule autre
option dans ce bus des toilettes aux
normes pmr cet équipement vos quatre
cent mille euros et pourrait s'intégrer
dans une offre de transports publics
destinés aux personnes à mobilité
réduite aujourd'hui ce qui est important
pour nous c'est de savoir que ce type de
véhicule existe pas en mode prototype
c'est l'industriel c'est la petite série
mais c'est important de voir que cette
offre serre et qu'elle a aujourd'hui une
réalité une utilité sur nos territoires
en particulier vis-à-vis des ccas les
centres communaux d'action sociale qui
ont des besoins de mobilité spécifiques
et aujourd'hui il ya un vrai plus de
voir ce type de véhicule arriver sur nos
territoires les associations comme l'afm
téléthon pourrait également être
intéressé par ce type de véhicule nous
pourrions être intéressée pour déplacer
toutes nos tous nos malades vers le
généthon que nous allons visiter
régulièrement par exemple à evry toutes
les structures pour l'école enfin où les
enfants malades vont par exemple se
rendent ça pourrait être une solution
aussi actuellement nous avons nous avons
beaucoup de soucis pour les taxis qui
transportent les enfants en fauteuil
encore de nombreuses problématiques à
résoudre pour l'accessibilité le groupe
lacroix et savak possède le plus grand
nombre de véhicules pmr en ile de france